.
Ich habe mir Gedanken gemacht.
Wie geht es einem solchen Menschen?
Dieses Wissen: "Ich gehe heute weg
und dann sterbe ich."
Es ist gut, dass er seinen
langjährigen Betreuer dabei hat.
Das wird ihm helfen.
Jürg Billwiller
will Sterbehelfer werden.
Doris Wartenweiler
begleitet ihn dabei.
Sie hat schon viel Erfahrung.
Für Billwiller ist es erst
die zweite Sterbebegleitung.
Mich beschäftigt dieser Mensch,
der die Entscheidung getroffen hat,
heute zu gehen.
Das ist sicher nicht einfach.
Was ist diese Nacht
in ihm vorgegangen?
Was sind das für Menschen, die
lernen, anderen den Tod zu bringen?
Davon handelt diese Geschichte.
Das wird gut besucht sein.
Es geht heute nach Bern.
Ein Patient hat sich
für den Freitod entschieden.
In seinem Heim darf er nicht sterben,
also muss eine andere Lösung her.
Verbunden mit einer Fahrt
in einem vollen Zug.
Stört es dich, wenn der
hier oben steht? - Nein.
Ich will ihn nicht
einfach irgendwo hinstellen.
An Entspannung während der Fahrt
ist nicht zu denken.
Sind Sie aufgeregt?
Angespannt.
Ich kenne die Person ja nicht.
Ich kenne nur das Krankheitsbild
aus dem Erstgespräch,
das Frau Wartenweiler
mit ihm geführt hat.
Aber sonst habe ich keine Kenntnis
darüber, wer diese Person ist.
Wie er aussieht.
Wie es ihm jetzt geht.
Alles, was es
für eine Freitodbegleitung braucht,
ist in diesem Koffer.
Und der wird gut bewacht.
Hier drin ist ...
... mein Material,
das ich für die Begleitung brauche.
Das lasse ich nicht aus den Augen.
Das Risiko ist zu gross.
Und hier sind die Unterlagen drin.
Den hätte ich da rauf legen können.
Aber mich stört es nicht.
Ich bin es gewohnt,
meine Sachen bei mir zu haben.
Aber die Flasche mit dem Gift
lassen Sie nicht aus den Augen?
Nein, das lasse ich
nicht aus den Augen.
Könnte denn etwas passieren?
Wenn es gestohlen würde,
hätte ich ein Riesenproblem.
Wenn die Person, die es
gestohlen hat, weiss, was es ist,
und es einnimmt ...
Ja.
Auch Sabine Schultze lässt sich
zur Sterbehelferin ausbilden.
Sie war Leiterin in einem Altersheim,
hat dort dafür gesorgt,
dass Exit den Bewohnern
das Sterbemittel bringen darf.
Der Tod hat Sabine Schultze
nie Angst eingejagt.
Sie kämpfte
gegen die katholische Überzeugung,
dass allein der Herrgott entscheidet,
wann ein Mensch stirbt.
Im Tagebuch beschrieb sie
den ersten Freitod im Heim.
Das war vor Urzeiten.
Einer hatte den Wunsch:
"Ich will gehen in aller Stille,
ohne Aufsehen. Das war möglich."
Das waren seine Worte.
Das war seine ...
Es war faszinierend,
dass er es so durchgezogen hat.
Sabine Schultze macht sich bereit
für die nächste Freitodbegleitung.
Sie überlässt nichts dem Zufall.
Nicht einmal beim Schminken.
Heute geht es in die Berge.
Also macht es Sinn ...
... wenn ich etwas sportlich wirke.
Es wird vielleicht kühl. Noch ist es
warm, aber es ist in der Höhe.
Und man weiss auch, dass man nicht
unbedingt Parfüm auftragen soll,
weil die Leute teils
in den letzten ...
... Stunden beim Sterben
ein ganz anderes Empfinden haben,
also Geschmack, Geruch.
Wir bereiten uns also
sehr neutral vor.
Sabine Schultze begleitet
Sterbewillige in Graubünden.
Das Gebiet ist ländlich,
die Wege sind lang.
Grüezi.
Schultze hat Zeit.
Mit 63 hat sie sich
pensionieren lassen.
An Ruhestand denkt sie aber nicht.
Sie will etwas Sinnvolles tun,
auch wenn nicht alle
Exit als etwas Sinnvolles erachten.
Es ist kein sexy Thema, das man
gleich mit neuen Bekanntschaften
oder neuen Beziehungen diskutiert.
Verständlich, absolut verständlich,
denn man hat wohl kein Bild davon,
wie es in der Realität ist.
Schultze macht
neben der Freitodbegleitung
derzeit eine zweite Ausbildung
als Wanderleiterin.
Vieles sei ähnlich, sagt sie.
Man gehe allein auf den Weg,
wisse nicht, was einen erwartet,
und müsse viel aushalten.
Der Zug nach Bern ist voll.
Der Mann, der heute
in den Tod begleitet wird,
macht den gleichen Weg mit dem Auto.
Ich nehme an,
sie sind jetzt unterwegs.
Ich denke schon.
Wobei der Zug
eigentlich einfacher ist.
Sicher, aber in solchen Momenten
will man sich wohl kaum
in einen Zug setzen.
Genau, richtig.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass
in einem Menschen viel abläuft,
wenn er weiss, dass es
seine letzte Fahrt sein wird.
Auf Sterbehelferinnen und -helfer
muss Verlass sein.
Wenn etwas im Zeitplan schiefgeht,
kommt schnell Stress auf.
Hier ist Wartenweiler, grüezi.
Unser Zug wurde umgeleitet. Es wird
bestimmt 10.40 Uhr, bis wir kommen.
Nur zur Information.
Nein. Nein, nein.
Das ist sicher,
denn wir verpassen den Anschlusszug.
Und ja, es wird sicher 10.40 Uhr.
Das wird sicher reichen,
und sonst nehmen wir ein Taxi.
Du hast abgemacht und gesagt,
dass wir etwas später kommen? - Ja.
Sabine Schultze hingegen
kommt pünktlich.
Hallo, Martin.
Sie trifft ihren Ausbilder.
Martin Krähenbühl
ist pensionierter Lehrer.
Seit Jahren ist er ein Begleiter
in den Tod im Auftrag von Exit.
Heute geht es
zu einem krebskranken Mann,
der täglich
von starken Schmerzen geplagt wird
und sich kaum noch bewegen kann.
Hast du eigentlich noch mal
mit ihnen telefoniert?
Ja, ich habe
mit der Tochter geredet.
Es ist so weit alles gut.
Ich habe noch
wegen des Trinkens gefragt.
Ob das immer noch gehe.
Sei meinte, es gehe gut.
Wir haben ihn einen Monat lang
nicht mehr gesehen.
Ja, wenn er nicht trinken kann,
müssen wir weiterschauen.
Dann müssen wir das Ganze
wahrscheinlich verschieben.
Aber im Moment sieht es aus,
als würde es klappen.
Okay.
Wer mit Exit sterben will,
muss den Becher mit dem Sterbemittel
selber dem Mund zuführen.
Niemand darf helfen,
sonst wäre es aktive Sterbehilfe,
und das ist strafbar.
Schultze und Krähenbühl
gehen allein weiter.
Ihre Arbeit zeigen wir nicht.
Zu privat, zu heikel.
Wenige Tage zuvor nahmen
die beiden angehenden Sterbehelfer
an einem Ausbildungstag teil.
Ornella Ferro, Leiterin
der Freitodbegleitung, erklärt,
wo die Neulinge aufpassen müssen.
Worauf ihr achten müsst
und was ihr den Personen
zur Vorbereitung
der oralen Einnahme sagen müsst,
ist, was sie vorher essen.
Wenn ihr am Morgen kommt, dürfen sie
am Abend zuvor zwar essen,
aber nicht
eine letzte grosse Mahlzeit,
alles essen, was sie sich wünschen.
Keine schwere Mahlzeit,
die aufliegt.
Das ist nicht gut, denn das kann
die Resorption verlangsamen.
Oder es kann dazu führen,
dass sie erbrechen müssen.
Die Teilnehmer lernen diesmal:
Wie wirkt das Mittel
möglichst schnell?
Die Sterbehelferinnen und -helfer
stossen immer wieder
auf Ängste und Misstrauen.
Natrium-Pentobarbital hat sich
als ganz sicheres Mittel erwiesen,
wenn jemand wirklich sterben will.
Und wenn man sich
einmal darauf eingestellt hat,
will man nicht mehr aufwachen.
Diese Sicherheit müssen wir geben.
In den Vorgesprächen
kommt häufig die Frage:
"Reicht die Dosierung, die ihr
mir gegeben habt, ganz sicher?"
"Sterbe ich dann wirklich?"
Es wird auch gefragt:
"Sind alle gestorben oder
ist schon mal jemand aufgewacht?"
Ihr könnt ganz beruhigt antworten,
dass bei uns
noch nie jemand aufgewacht ist.
Mir ist kein Fall bekannt.
Schauen wir mal,
wo wir durchmüssen.
Billwiller und Wartenweiler
sind endlich in Bern.
Verspätet.
Aber wo fährt das Tram?
Die beiden haben extra den Zug
genommen, um pünktlich zu sein.
Und jetzt das.
Bern-Brünnen heisst es.
Und wir müssen wissen,
auf welche Seite.
Oh, das auch noch.
Ah, gut. Fährt das?
- Ja, das ist das richtige.
Es muss ganz in der Nähe sein.
Wir müssen einfach gut aufpassen,
wo wir durchlaufen.
Gehen wir in die richtige Richtung?
- Nicht sicher.
Ist es Ihnen unangenehm, dass der
Sterbewillige auf Sie warten muss?
Es löst kein gutes Gefühl aus.
Ich finde es nicht gut,
dass es so gelaufen ist,
dass er jetzt warten muss.
Wir fragen das Taxi.
Wo ist diese Strasse? Nr. 70.
Gut. Merci!
Die beiden haben den Weg gefunden.
Von nun an gehen sie ohne uns weiter.
3 Std. später tragen die Bestatter
den Sarg in den Leichenwagen.
Aus dem Gebäude kommen
die beiden Exit-Mitarbeitenden.
Müde und aufgewühlt.
Wie hast du es empfunden?
Für ihn hat es wirklich gestimmt.
Man hat gemerkt,
dass er einfach nicht mehr kann.
Das stimmt.
Er hat auch gesagt,
er wolle noch mal rausgehen,
seine letzte Zigarette rauchen,
die Hunde noch mal streicheln.
Das war ein Moment, den er -
ich sage es mal so - genossen hat.
Genau.
Als er hereinkam,
hat er nicht mehr gezögert.
Er sagte,
er wolle sich jetzt hinlegen.
"Leitet das Ganze in die Wege!"
Ich fragte ihn, ob er etwas spüre.
Er sagte zuerst: "Noch nicht."
Dann sagte er:
"Nun merke ich, dass es einfährt."
Dann wurde er müde
und der Kopf neigte sich zur Seite.
Für mich war das das Zeichen,
dass er tief schläft,
keine Schmerzen,
kein Empfinden mehr hat.
So fiel er ins Koma, und
irgendwann hörte sein Kreislauf auf.
So starb er.
Es ist wirklich sanft.
Das sagten auch die Anwesenden.
Es sei wirklich ein sanftes Sterben,
so wünsche man sich das Sterben.
Im Bündnerland ist es Nacht geworden.
Sabine Schultze und Martin Krähenbühl
kommen von der Sterbebegleitung
zurück.
Sie sind erschöpft, aber zufrieden.
Alles lief gut.
Der alte, kranke Mann ist tot.
Wie war es heute für dich?
Diese Begleitung?
Die Begleitung
war für mich wirklich gut.
Ich merkte aber, dass es
sehr lange dauerte, und fragte mich,
was so besonders war, denn so lange
hatte es vorher nie gedauert.
Das ist richtig. Es dauerte
mit dem Arzt relativ lange.
Er hat mit dem Polizisten
noch verschiedene Dinge besprochen,
die diese Person betreffen.
Es war für alle neu, richtig?
Ja.
Freunde und Verwandte sind gekommen,
um den gebrechlichen Mann
beim Sterben zu begleiten.
Ist dir auch aufgefallen,
dass er, der Sterbewillige,
eigentlich niemanden von der Familie
hätte dabei haben wollen?
Stimmt mein Eindruck?
- Er stimmt.
Es ist oft so,
dass die sterbewilligen Personen
das ihren Kindern
"nicht antun" wollen.
Nicht zumuten.
Sabine Schultze ist froh,
jetzt allein zu sein.
Einen Menschen sterben zu sehen,
das steckt niemand einfach so weg.
Zurück zur Schulung bei Exit.
Die neuen Freitodbegleiter
stellen hier die Fragen,
die in der Praxis auftauchen.
Wie sollen sie reagieren, wenn
beim Verabreichen des Sterbemittels
etwas Unvorhergesehenes passiert?
Wie ist das,
wenn jemand es getrunken hat,
das Glas wegstellt
und erbrechen muss?
Reicht dann das,
was er geschluckt hat,
oder kommt dann
die Reserve zum Einsatz?
Es reicht. Das ist ganz wichtig.
Es kam schon öfter vor, dass
jemand erbrochen hat - unerwartet.
Gar nicht erwartet.
Es kam auch schon vor, dass
jemand im Schwall erbrochen hat.
Diese Personen sind alle gestorben.
Es war nicht so,
dass es viel länger dauerte.
Vielleicht dauert es
ein paar Minuten länger.
Ihr müsst ...
Es ist ein Schock für alle.
Es ist ganz wichtig,
dass ihr die Ruhe bewahrt.
Jürg Billwiller
hat die Erfahrung gemacht,
dass Angehörige geschockt sind,
wenn sie den Leichnam sehen,
umringt von Polizei und Amtsarzt.
Wenn er im Fernsehsessel sitzt,
weil er immer da gesessen hat,
und stirbt,
muss man den Angehörigen sagen,
dass, wenn der Tod eingetreten ist
und die Legalinspektion stattfindet,
der Leichnam am Boden liegt
und nicht mehr im Sessel ist.
Und in der Regel
liegt er nackt dort.
Das sollte man
den Angehörigen sagen.
Er sitzt dann
nicht mehr angezogen im Sessel.
Sorgt vorher auch dafür,
dass eine Decke vorhanden ist.
Wenn es im Bett stattfindet,
gibt es eine Decke.
Aber auch sonst
soll eine Decke bereit sein.
Sorgt vor der Begleitung dafür,
sodass die Behörden
nach der Legalinspektion
den Körper zudecken können.
Die Angehörigen sollen wissen,
dass er nicht mehr dort sitzt,
wo er verstorben ist.
Und evtl. sind die Kleider
zerschnitten, das kam schon vor.
Das finde ich auch unmöglich.
Dann muss man
den Angehörigen vielleicht sagen,
dass sie Kleider bereitlegen sollen.
Tschüss zusammen, macht es gut!
Medizin, Jura, Psychologie:
Die Sterbehelfer müssen
von allem eine Ahnung haben.
Die Ausbildung dauert rund ein Jahr.
Wir haben festgestellt,
dass der Kopf voll ist
und nichts mehr reingeht.
So, ich packe zusammen.
Jürg Billwiller
hatte ein Inserat gelesen,
in dem Exit Freitodbegleiter suchte.
Er bewarb sich. Das Rentnerleben
war ihm zu langweilig.
Auf dem Weg nach Hause
kommt Billwiller
am Polizeigefängnis in Zürich vorbei.
Sechs Jahre lang
hat er diese Anstalt geleitet.
Damals wollte er
mit allen Mitteln verhindern,
dass Insassen sich das Leben nehmen.
Es war ein Kampf gegen Windmühlen.
Die Erfahrung hat gezeigt:
Die Insassen zeigen einem
immer wieder einen Weg,
wie es auch noch geht, selbst
wenn man sich als erfahrener Mann
Gedanken über eine Zelle macht:
Wo könnte man noch etwas machen?
Ich dachte oft, wir seien so weit,
dass nichts mehr passieren kann.
Aber die Insassen zeigten uns:
Man findet immer eine Möglichkeit.
Billwiller gab nicht auf.
Er liess die Kajütenbetten
in den Zellen entfernen,
vor die Gitter an den Fenstern
montierte er Panzerglas.
Niemand -
das war Billwillers fester Wille -
sollte sich mehr
strangulieren können.
Als Gefängnisleiter versuchten Sie
früher mit aller Kraft,
die Gefangenen vom Suizid abzuhalten,
nun arbeiten Sie bei Exit
und helfen beim Suizid.
Warum machen Sie nun
genau das Gegenteil?
Ein Suizid in einem Gefängnis
ist oft eine Kurzschlussreaktion.
In dieser Situation,
unter diesem Druck, passiert das.
Jemand, der freiwillig sterben will,
geht nicht, weil Druck herrscht.
Oder wir würden es nicht machen,
wenn Druck besteht.
Tätigkeit: Sterbehelfer.
Damit geht Billwiller
nicht gerade hausieren.
Erzählen Sie Ihrem Umfeld,
dass Sie die Ausbildung
zum Freitodbegleiter machen?
Ja, den Personen, bei denen
ich denke, dass es wichtig ist,
dass sie es wissen, sage ich es.
Die anderen
erfahren es sonst irgendwie.
Mein Freundeskreis weiss es.
Und auch die ganze Familie.
Das reicht vorläufig für mich.
Hallo!
Der Ausbildungstag ist zu Ende.
Bin wieder hier.
Mit Ehefrau Gabi
kann Billwiller alles durchgehen,
was sich tagsüber aufgestaut hat.
Das Zuhause ist sein Rückzugsort.
Billwiller ist müde und hungrig.
Es gibt Spaghetti Bolognese
und einen Entschluss,
was die Sterbebegleitung betrifft.
Wir haben schon mal
darüber gesprochen.
Ich habe heute definitiv Ja gesagt.
Ich mache weiter.
Es ist immer noch
voll in meinem Interesse.
Ich bin voll davon überzeugt,
dass es eine gute Sache ist.
Ja.
Ich finde es schön,
dass es Leute gibt, die das machen.
Ich glaube, ich könnte es nicht.
Aber dich hat das
schon immer fasziniert.
Ich war schon immer ...
- Das Soziale, oder ...
... ein Helfertyp.
Helfen ist gut und schön. Aber
die Ehe sollte nicht darunter leiden.
Als er nach dem ersten Mal
nach Hause kam, fragte ich mich,
wie er das wohl verarbeiten würde.
Ich sass draussen,
es war schönes Wetter.
Er kam zur Tür herein,
ich sagte Hallo.
Er ging gleich in sein Zimmer.
Da liess ich ihn in Ruhe.
Ich war angespannt, weil ich dachte,
wenn er es nicht gut verkraftet
oder ich merke, dass es nicht gut
geht, dann würde ich ehrlich sagen,
dass er nicht weitermachen soll.
Würdest du bitte den Tisch decken?
Mache ich.
Ausnahmsweise decke ich den Tisch.
Menschen den Todesbecher reichen.
Ihnen beim Sterben zusehen.
Wie verkraftet Billwiller das?
Wenn ich ein Ritual habe,
wenn ich jemanden gehen lasse,
dann ist es, dass ich das Fenster
öffne, damit die Seele raus kann.
Und ich ziehe mich danach zurück,
fahre einen Moment runter.
Das hilft mir.
Ich machte das
schon früher beim Arbeiten so.
Ich konnte mich zurückziehen,
dann ging es sehr gut.
Die Zahl der Freitodbegleitungen
steigt.
Schon wieder sucht Exit
per Inserat neue Bewerber.
Doch nur wenige trauen sich zu,
diesen Job zu machen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
A. Duttweiler, L. Zbinden - 2019